you don't have that many opportunity to
run something this big and not
potentially have something go wrong with
a lot of risks when it comes to
waterfalls especially with drop this
side
if i approach it like i just want to do
this once even though it's one of the
most glorious drop i just want to hit my
line one and not have to run it again
that moment when it was time to come
over it literally looks like you're
falling off the face of the earth
[Music]
my name is dane jackson i'm a
professional white water kayaker i do
freestyle i'll be racing a big waterfall
whatever it is that seemed exciting at
the time
i first started kayaking when i was
about two years old that's when i ran my
first river when i was born my dad was
already a professional kayak he got a 92
olympics and he was also a pro freestyle
world champion so he made sure to get me
and follow my sister pretty much right
away and have a kai mahal
it's so loud
over my career i've been fortunate
enough to have a lot of great successes
i won a lot of extreme races that won a
lot of combination events like the white
water grand prix um but i've also done
expeditions all over the world
i got to run the south o'malley
waterfall in chile which is the second
tallest job that's been run the drops
right about 134 feet there's a drop i
dreamed about doing
every waterfall was different and had
their own kind of unique challenges the
malay waterfall made it really
challenging but that lip is a it's a
very fast moving kind of spout of water
and sometimes that can be really tricky
to really set your angle because you're
coming off with a lot of speed
i unfortunately didn't have the most
perfect line that i could have i set my
angle good had a super soft hit but the
issue was that my skirt had come off my
boat my boat filled up with water and i
did have to come out of my boat in the
boils after in a perfect world i would
have stayed in my boat i would have
paddled away and it would have been a
perfect descent but in the end i was
still able to get my composure and have
a good line it was an incredible
experience that was by far one of the
second jobs i've ever done that view was
mind-blowing so when it comes to running
bigger waterfalls our ultimate goal is
to land as vertical as possible with our
bodies tucked up because if you were to
land flat off of a drop especially a bad
size there's a good chance you might
break your back so that is probably the
ultimate worst case when it comes to
running something like that a lot of
people always assume when they see us
running these big waterfalls that we're
just the daredevils that don't take any
safety precautions and just fall off of
these things without any skill and get
lucky where in the end there's actually
there's a lot of things that we have to
look at before we can make the decision
that not only can i run it not trust my
skill to run it but i can be helped if
something were to go wrong
in the end there's just so much risk
with waterfalls that tall that all you
can really get stoked on is the fact
that you're able to run it and not get
hurt
i love the opportunity to go fall off
something like sakamale
i'm simply doing it because i love
kayaking
[Music]
[Music]
you